un día crucial para el futuro del
movimiento el sábado la movilización
contra la reforma a las pensiones
registró su nivel de participación más
bajo cuatro jornadas después del récord
de afluencia del 7 de marzo pero para el
secretario general de la confederación
francesa democrática del trabajo la
asistencia de este miércoles no es algo
importante es necesario que haya el
máximo número de personas pero hemos
demostrado que ha habido una gran
movilización contra la reforma de las
pensiones la movilización social ya es
un éxito el fracaso es la capacidad de
escuchar a la otra parte el objetivo de
los sindicatos es incluir en los últimos
debates parlamentarios este miércoles la
comisión mixta se reúne para ultimar el
texto antes de una votación de las dos
cámaras del parlamento que se dará el
jueves una votación para la que El
Ejecutivo cuenta con mayoría según la
primera ministra Elizabeth
existe una mayoría para garantizar el
futuro de nuestras pensiones y asumir
mañana desacuerdos u oposiciones francas
sobre otros temas ustedes expresarán
entonces sobre la reforma de las
pensiones no sobre un apoyo al gobierno
sino sobre este proyecto sobre este
proyecto solamente un voto directo pero
peligroso para El Ejecutivo que
multiplica las negociaciones para
obtener los votos de los diputados de
los republicanos si no tiene mayoría
absoluta el gobierno podría utilizar el
artículo 49:3 para aprobar el texto sin
votación